sciences po victime d'une descente du
bus de l'organisation d'étudiants
d'extrême droite
un commando d'une demi douzaine de
jeunes hommes a mené l'opération
avant-hier deux d'entre s'attaquant à la
table des syndicats de gauche de
personnes sont entrées de zone avec un
foulard sur le visage et des gangs qui
ont commencé à arracher le panneau
dessus des le panneau du défilé et
ensuite donc moi g
j'ai pris la fuite et je suis tombé
ensuite ils ont renversé tous les tracts
qui avait sur la table et ils s'en sont
pris ensuite à julien et un appariteur
qu'ils ont raison de laisser qu'un peu
aux américains les demandes du cuse ont
pris la fuite au fond des tracts
gauchistes en des facs
si les guides sorbonne a qu'une croix
celtique cette exaction suit une série
d'incidents dans les facs parisiennes
depuis la rentrée un regain d'activisme
revendiqué dans une interview par le
responsable du cud nostalgique de
l'époque où son organisation était la
hantise de la fac de droit d'assas
benoît fleury annonce le retour du gud
groupe non interdite en matière de
liberté d'expression
ce qui est intolérable et ne peut être
tolérée par aucun président d'université
c'est que l'on passe des paroles à les
actes violents
c'est ce qu'indique un dollar ça va
peut-être conforter leurs militants dans
leur logique de bravade viril ce dock
guerrière mais paul du leur image son
stress ça va les aider dans le milieu
universitaire hypothèses sur survival
mégrétistes et lepéniste joue au plus
musclées pour s'imposer sur fond de
recul général dans les facs